foreign
[Music]
because it does literally that's it
flies into the Target and that's
distinct from a Us Predator or Reaper
drone which might launch its munition
and then fly back to base to be
re-equipped and flying on the day so a
Kamikaze drone is a One-Shot weapon
[Music]
thank you
as far as Russians are concerned they're
probably employing weapons as soon as
they can get their hands on them but at
the same time it means that Russia isn't
depleting its more expensive rarer
stocks of precision guided Munitions and
cruise missiles which it can't use
indefinitely against Ukrainian cities
and Military targets
the introduction of Russia's Kamikaze
drones will give the ukrainians yet
another weapon system to worry about to
defend against and I think overall it's
not going to change the war we often
hear about the introduction of new
weapon systems more often on the
Ukrainian side supplied by NATO now of
course being procured by Russia they
forced an adaption from the opponent
because they produce a different
Battlefield effect that requires
different defensive techniques but in of
themselves no one weapon system of this
nature can change the outcome of the war
[Music]
thank you